okay here's a company that does not
share our values uh several weeks ago
netflix began promoting a new film from
french director
maimuna dankori probably mispronouncing
that but
uh the movie is called cuties and the
poster featuring scantily
children posing suggestively caused
well-deserved outrage when it first
appeared the sundance film festival
which honored the film with a directing
award
provided a synopsis that didn't do much
to quell the anger either according to
sundance
cuties tells the story of an 11 year old
girl named amy who
quote through an ignited awareness of
her burgeoning femininity
propels the group to enthusiastically
embrace
an increasingly sensual dance routine uh
sparking the girls hope to torque their
way to stardom
at a local dance contest it's perhaps
perhaps worth mentioning here that
sundance was co-founded by a man
who is now in prison for child sexual
abuse i don't know i just want to
throw that in there the film's official
description from netflix was only
slightly less grotesque sounding
and they they said amy 11 becomes
fascinated with a twerking dance crew
hoping to join them
she starts to explore her femininity
defying her family's traditions
now after the backlash netflix
apologized not for the film itself but
simply for the inappropriate artwork
they said the streaming service also
changed the synopsis getting rid of any
mention of twerking
and instead calling it a free spirited
dance group
netflix did not bother to explain why
they used that
quote-unquote inappropriate artwork in
the first place to promote
the film you know if it doesn't actually
reflect the content
and if they're not trying to attract an
audience of pedophiles who wish to see
pubescent girls gyrate on stage then
what was the thought process behind the
way it was originally marketed
we were never told the website bustle
said that
the poster was simply botched now i can
understand
botching a poster with a typo or some
other error due to carelessness but
how do you botch something by
accidentally turning it into softcore
child porn that's my question
many other media outlets rushed to the
defense of the twerking children movie
an article by annamenta on the decider
scolded the film's detractors
baselessly linking the criticism to the
q anon conspiracy theory
and said that we all owe the director an
apology
richard broder at the new yorker called
the movie extraordinary
and blasted the scurrilous campaign
launched by right wingers to criticize
the movie
the rolling stones david fear gave
cuties a positive review saying that the
outrage is all the product of a
major misleading marketing mistake the
independent
joined the chorus of defenders declaring
uh quote cuties on netflix is too moving
a film to be marred by
one bad taste poster many outlets such
as npr claim that the film
actually criticizes and exposes the
sexualization of children
actress tessa thompson said that she was
gutted by the
quote beautiful film and that the quote
current discourse
misses the fact that the movie comments
on the hypersexualization of
pre-adolescent girls overall
the outrage certainly did not deter the
media from hailing cuties as an artistic
triumph as you could tell
in fact as we speak it sits at 90
percent fresh
on review aggregator site rotten
tomatoes with critics saying other
things like
it's refreshingly frank about class
religion and burgeoning sexuality
in ways that mainstream american movies
would never dare and also quote
cuties certainly deserves to be seen
for a while the film's valiant defenders
in the media in hollywood
had the advantage of being the only
people to have actually seen it
uh the rest of us could but make
assumptions based on the it would seem
rather significant fact
that it's a movie about 11 year olds
twerking which netflix had decided to
market with a picture of said 11 year
olds
barely clothed and striking sexual poses
but
you can't judge a movie by its child
porn cover we were told
and then yesterday the film was finally
released it turns out
unsurprisingly you can as
fuller clips from the film now circulate
online i won't play any of them here
because honestly i'd worry about the fbi
breaking down my door if i did
it's clear that those of us who
criticized the movie actually
understated our case it is if anything
way
worse than we assumed and feared
some examples one scene features the 11
year old girls gyrating and slapping
each other on the butt
as the camera zooms in for close-ups
another shows amy in her underwear
furiously thrusting her body as she lays
on the floor
again camera gives close-ups in another
the girls dance provocatively for two
grown men
one of whom looks on with obvious and
creepy satisfaction
and still another amy pulls down her
pants and takes a picture of her crotch
and posts it online
and the pen in the penultimate scene
which was featured on the original
poster before netflix changed it
that scene is significantly more
disturbing than the already disturbing
image led on
the scene drags on for several minutes
the dancing is
highly highly sexualized and the camera
as always
zooms in for crotch shots and other
close-ups
this is not a commentary on child sexual
exploitation
it is child exploitation clear as day
in all its sadism and remember the
characters
and the actors who play them are 11
years old
with these horrific scenes now publicly
available it seems almost
pointless to engage with the plainly
absurd notion
that the filmmakers had 11 year old
children writhe around and gyrate on
stage
while barely clothed as some kind of
protest against the sexualization of
children
it would be like a slasher film
featuring several scenes of various
screaming victims being disemboweled
claiming in its defense that it only
meant to comment
on the problem of graphic violence in
film indeed
that actually is the defense often
offered for slasher fix
flicks and and it's as weak in that case
as it is here the guy who made
texas chainsaw massacre may have told
himself that he had higher intentions
but the fact remains
that most people who watch texas
chainsaw massacre just want to see
well a chainsaw massacre i suppose when
it comes down to it
no filmmaker wants to come out and admit
that they produced gratuitous
garbage for a lowest common denominator
audience but many filmmakers
do produce that sort of material for
that sort of audience
whether they admit it or not and cuties
belongs
on that ghastly heap for sure hopefully
buried underneath it somewhere
deep where it cannot be seen despite the
pretensions of anamenta
at the decider and many others in media
the normalization of pedophilia
is not a right-wing fairy tale or a q
anon conspiracy theory
it is real it is happening
here's exhibit a or you know not even
exhibit a i mean
this is a long line of exhibits it's
it's right in front of us
for us to see you know um
yes do you have the normalization of
pedophilia in a culture
where a movie like this not just exists
okay it's not just that some some
pervert some creep made this movie and
it's it's out there in the hinterland
somewhere uh out on the fringes and no
one's seen it this is being
uh promoted
and and supplied to us to the to the
american audience
by a billion dollar streaming platform
and
major media publications have come out
in its defense
strenuously uh to defend it
you wouldn't have that in a culture that
didn't normalize
pedophilia and child sexual exploitation
i mean this is this is a country where
children are sent to the library to be
read stories by drag queens
uh this is a country where uh you know
planned parenthood
goes into middle schools and high
schools to hand out birth control
this is a country where we've got you
know quote unquote sex ed in elementary
schools
telling kids about masturbation and
other things
so yes this is a a real
plan uh among the powers that be in our
culture to sexualize
children there is no doubt about it
and this right here from netflix i mean
if this is not
reason if this if this does not convince
us all to cancel our netflix
subscriptions if we still have them
then um then i don't know what will
there have to be real penalties for
something like this
we can't just complain about it and say
how horrible this is and then go about
our married
merry way while still paying netflix our
subscription fee
we cannot do that uh if there was ever
a reason for a boycott this is it right
here
so let's all do that today let's cancel
our netflix subscriptions that's that's
the least we can do that's step one
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video uh be
sure to give it a like
and a subscribe to our youtube channel
so you don't miss out on any of our
content